if LeBron James tells me to shoot the
ball like this i'ma start shooting the
ball like that cuz successful yeah
comics doing this and he's killing on
the road a ticket yeah and I don't give
a [ __ ] him in New York and an Africa at
the LA guys in like damn all these boys
are selling the shows that all these
boys are crushing podcast yeah you know
what it is it's like mmm weird right
what it is is is when you have they have
like a there's like a famine mentality
out there cuz you can actually make
money doing comedy in New York like
spots yeah like that's that's why money
is all relative everything's relative
but like the West Coast guys you guys
all got rich cuz you can't make no
[ __ ] money out here right like I
remember once I did a spot at the at the
Hollywood improv great Club and then she
tried to make me sign a www.911.gov yeah
I don't know where we make money out
here like if he does show on the main
room you can I mean you could no no no
what I mean Spa pay so like nap there
was a time in LA when I would come here
back in the day and it was like you make
ten fifty seven fifty ten dollars for
these just little spots not headlining a
show doing 15 minutes yeah right now
maybe that money's going up it's
different yeah right but there was a
time where it didn't it didn't seem like
you were making enough money to sustain
yourself make a living figure out you
know acting more the other things
podcasting right like you guys real
webseries writing like everybody here
was doing something else as well and you
found out how to make that other thing
you know make you guys millions of
dollars so it's like back home I think
was crippling is that comics in New York
can make just enough money to survive
that's all they have the spots and I
think inherently comics are lazy I think
the ones that aren't end up doing really
well but will do the least amount of
work to get the thing we want you know
and if you ask a lot of comments like
man I just want to make a living at this
and [ __ ] that's all you'll do
yeah if that's where you said it you're
there you won't go any you might not
even get there but you will not go any
further so the worst thing
New York is often the best thing right
the best thing about New York says all
this stage time and as all these guys
are amazing the worst thing is that you
can get the golden handcuffs you can get
all this stage 9 what you want to just
barely make a living now if you're just
barely making living do you have enough
to share or help no no because if you
take one spot from me it's problems it's
like well how am I gonna pay my rent so
now you're not really helping now you
really fighting for yours that makes
sense right
where is where is I imagine out here you
know
you know spots are still competitive
that kind of stuff but guys are trying
to get on the road yeah guys are trying
to open for people etc yeah so what I
try to just get guys to realize is like
the comedy in New York is the gym it has
to be your gym that is not your angle I
know there's a lot of guys in New York
like I mean I just wanna get past in the
cellar and that's gonna be it's like I
was just talking about L last week and I
was like that's the problem the
mentalities people just go I want to be
in the cellar and then that's it and
it's like he goes no no this is the gym
this is where you work out you make your
living on the road yep you know but it's
like the oh geez understood that the
older guys understood but I think the
younger guys looked up to those og so
much and they kind of just and they like
they had this romantic view of what that
would be like so they stopped dreaming
past that and what I'm trying to get
them to do is like understand what gets
you past that because those old G's
though that nobody's goal should be to
just do spot to the cellar the goal
should be you just walk in and be a god
I'll do some time yeah like my goal even
even in the city and there's a lot of
great clubs in the city there's New York
Comedy Club amazing the stand is really
good
and obviously the cellar really good
really good place like Gotham right
Gotham's more of a headliner Club those
are like the headliner you're not doing
spots there nah
oh no maybe I'll pop in I'll do like a
comedy juice I'm so like that but uh but
there's a lot of great stage time but
what what I got to get them to realize
is this is a means to an end like I
never in my whole career looked at the
cellar as at the end I was like oh I
want to be here because it's always sold
out and I can work out material more
yeah it was there for me to work out
material even I remember I first got
passed there and it was like I was
trying to joke some people like what are
you worried about trying to you jokes
I'm like well what's the point
well it'll be in here like yeah how
would I know if they work yeah like I'm
gonna do my
best best [ __ ] for $25 yeah if we do the
road you know I mean you're makin you
want ice [ __ ] on the road yeah I'll try
say whatever but I guess my point is
you're well now gears because you're you
know you're you but before if you were
younger let's say your headlight in your
first 2 or 3 years you're on the road
you start doing [ __ ] crowd work for
30 minutes but I'm not coming Robert
yeah I guess it's just [ __ ]
that's it sucks crowd you know you
should never do that guys never do a
whole now never do a whole town now dog
when you first start headlining like you
gotta bring your a materialman
ya know you got a kill absolutely you
got a kill inlet and if you're not good
at you know crowd work and don't do it
if you're not good at those times things
don't don't do it you got a murder but
that was my philosophy was it was just
like hey I want to make sure that you
want to come back next year
that's always what I'm thinking everyone
should be yet dude you gotta mark you so
let's take it there's problem yeah and
happens oh yeah you know and
[ __ ] have herbs and flows like
I get it like someone had like a big pop
because of something you know you could
do like the Correspondents Dinner or
some [ __ ] like that you know what I mean
like everybody knows you and then
afterwards it's not as popular but
that's an ebb and flow is gonna be
natural in a career it's entertainment
yeah it's part of it but that's what
that's it's just getting people
understand their there are things that
you dream bigger you go bigger but I've
put up the guys in your like Sodor and
[ __ ] Normie like everyone have
they're doing it they're doing it
there's an article yet they still do you
know you talk to normally talk to soda
that there's there like that we
shouldn't have to do social media but we
do it yes one of those things where it's
just like yeah I'm sure basketball
players wish they didn't have to you
know jog what you do yeah it's a new
business yeah it's like it's like with
with MMA is like I'm sure bad day
[ __ ] like I don't wanna learn
jujitsu Wow yeah they didn't have to I'm
a bar fighter I just want to go with
nothing on a dude yeah don't go to the
ground I'm what is this ground [ __ ] like
I'm not good enough to be a boxer I just
want to go hook off on somebody yeah
right and then all sudden these jujitsu
guys come into that god I gotta learned
you just need to learn it and now it's a
whole different group of comics coming
up who started young I was talking about
this with Mark yesterday it's like now
that the internet exists comics are
starting young you got comics that are
twenty four years old been doing
economy for six years yeah what yeah you
know so and all these comments coming up
there coming up watching our [ __ ]
so they're like okay I got to know how
to edit video I got to know how to you
know add sub times I know how to Clips I
gotta do all so they're coming up and
it's like if you want to stay in the
game you better know how to compete yep
you know it's like LeBron learned how to
shoot threes you know cuz he had to
Jordan developed a fadeaway
cuz he had to yeah you know it's you're
not gonna stay in this game off of just
your name and people in New York going I
like you you ever to keep out here I
mean there's some guys who got
grandfathered in rightfully so like
Chappell or some [ __ ] like that but
those days are kind of it's gonna be
tough man unless you're on YouTube or
it's a new game through the social media
it's a new [ __ ] game and you
know what you should be excited because
you actually got some [ __ ] leverage
now I don't you don't have to suck dick
at these [ __ ] comedy festivals where
everybody's kissing up to the the
network execs yeah I'll go to jfl and
I'll go out to dinner yeah during I'm
not losing execs no I don't hang out I'm
like I'm doing jfl I take my guys me too
that's what they give my guys I do the
show and I'm I'm if my boys are there
I'll see you know comics yeah I'm out
that's what I want to talk to him out
and even if I want to talk to like like
even I was talking to one of guys jfl
the other day the other day he was at
the stand and I was just like yo what do
you look for for new faces because I got
friends of mine who for some reason
value that [ __ ] which is there's no
reason you should value it but they do
they think is gonna change what goes
back in the day pit like Kevin Hart had
a natural set in Montreal
yeah [ __ ] you know everything you got
poppin absolutely now there's so many
today have a different hand on your
castle was dope yeah yeah you're right
yeah it's just a different game now is
it that being said like YouTube is there
felt like [ __ ] know about you
already
yeah I don't got to go to the show yeah
click a video watch it and anyone can
watch it not just the crowd at JFS oasis
changing bro it's like oh you know it is
it is just it's all changing dude I I
don't know how much longer agents are
gonna be around or managers that's legit
like let's be honest
cuz they're just but I love this book in
your venue yeah like he's in his TJ TJ
Mark Walter I love you
you're my guys you're always gonna be
with me and iris so he doesn't get
nervous for that kind of shot I'm gonna
see no no that's my grammar Sadie
[ __ ] like it fine
it's in your hands it's a matter of fact
you're fired no but uh but like what
I've said to him is this is like alright
so you have these promoters this is what
a lot of people don't understand about
the game once you get out of comedy
clubs when you're in economy clubs is
easy agent calls a comedy club comedy
club puts a show on you do the show then
you start getting into theatres right so
the agent doesn't call it theater I just
had to learn about this [ __ ] the agent
calls a promoter it's how I like Live
Nation yeah yeah Live Nation AEG any of
these other so agent calls a promoter
the promoter calls a theater the
promoter puts on a show right promoter
pays me why do I need my agent to do
that yeah what I told my agent was like
you gotta be careful because you don't
realize it but you're about to be boxed
out it's just like uber drivers like
right now there's people listening to
the power guys driving uber thinking
they got his sweet
the second uber finds a way to drive
that car without you you are out of a
job fam I mean you got probably four or
five years well if you plan on living
more than four or five years even if you
might have not figure that [ __ ] out you
might figure it out okay so so the thing
with the agent so I told him I was like
you realize that they're slowly getting
rid of you like they do all the
promotion they have all the ticketing
they have everything I'm a union 10% you
can handle the acts that do the comedy
clubs but once you get to the acts for
theatres right I could literally call up
Live Nation tomorrow or AG or any of
these companies tomorrow and just say
hey yeah I'm ready to go back on tour
new hour yeah you just booked all the
things here's the thing though you know
you know some of the legs myself
replaceable Live Nation's some of those
other ones yeah though can I have
friends who go to go oh you have a tour
well we want you only to perform at our
venues yeah and they go here's a flat
rate we don't give a [ __ ] how many
tickets you sell you let us promote it
you do your thing on your end but the
we're give you a flat rate thank you let
me do that and it's big bleh money so
I'm taking like you
all the works done that's what I told my
agent my agent yeah this was great and I
love it my agent brought it to me
he brought the deal to me and I was like
why what are you doing you got to do
this they wouldn't go direct to you
though they could I could go but they
obviously though family they offered me
seven figures for one year of touring
right and then when you break it up to
the amount of shows and that kind of
stuff you could see if it's worth it
this that the other but when I'm telling
my agent I'm like yeah you could do this
like you got to do all this I don't
understand
no you're the only way your agent
shouldn't be fired if they said let's
say they offered you three million to do
this my agent is you wetbacks like yo we
need five yeah no no my age that's what
you don't want to do ya know my agent
turned a yeah like he deserves it he's a
piece in like he does a lot of like
almost managerial stuff as well like
that's my partner I look at him as my
business man
he happens to be part of a heap happens
to be part of an agency is definitely
get fired but yeah but I'll take them
yeah do it as a friend yeah that's right
you know know we'll be your sister yeah
yeah can't be my agent be my assistant
but you see where it's going right hi
now with all the podcasts everything is
so niche we have our following we have
all that kind of stuff it's like like
you'll have a agent handling your
podcast stuff right no no I don't even
know what my agency does everyone so
i'll call them they'll beg yo you know
this show looks kind of cool hot ones
yeah yeah I don't want to check out hot
ones in the big all right we're gonna
look into that and then they do jack
[ __ ] you heard from they do nothing
comfort you can't just call the [ __ ]
show so I eat the spicy chips okay I
mean they're based out of New York an
easy one bro they don't do anything none
of these people do anything that's it
that's what I realize about this whole
business nobody does anything it's all
incoming calls well yeah I don't think
what's on cruises sorry agent is really
like pitching [ __ ] he's just waiting
missing a possible 1400 Tom hey Tom
looks like this they haven't figured out
the missions pretty possible yeah you
keep on doing it every single [ __ ]
time it is weird like you want to ask
them like theme Monday through
thirty nine to five home I go yeah you
you email me an offer from Cleveland or
Dubrow but the rest of the day what
would you say you do for bright like
what's going on the rest of the day my
agents hustling - my PA agent is
hustling the other ones jobless like
normal but mine but now that's what I
got ya know I know because he's that's
my guy man like I'm a very loyal dude to
people who like sacrifice I'm really
ride or die for me yeah so that's
important to me and if you have those
guys you take care of them yeah like
real let them go we're gonna let him go
yeah I mean like he's it's time
bro
are we gonna do it Dada Dada I love them
I love us right now yeah yeah yeah yeah
watch your tongue oh good what's gonna
happen what are you gonna do use some of
that boxing you've been doing
[Laughter]